thank you for joining me today guys um
at a lunchtime on a Friday afternoon um
today I will be talking about
collaboration best practices um within
data science teams using the power of
data science
notebooks okay let
see as a quick introduction of myself
I'm Megan I'm a data advocate hit at
deepnote where I am responsible for
creating resources for users and
developers of deepnote to use the
product better prior to deepnote I was a
data scientist at narrator where I was
helping to build Advanced analytics
tooling for data analysts and data
scientists first what is deepnote it is
essentially a data science notebook that
helps teams collaborate so that they can
tackle the hardest data problems
together deepnote allows you to combine
SQL python R and no code visualization
blocks together it has over 50 native
Integrations that allow you to query
from the most popular data
sources you can also use our um AI Suite
of tools to generate edit um and fix
bugs in your code and also take it to
the next level of generating an entire
notebook for you um just with a simple
prompt and
lastly you can turn the insights that
you get from The Notebook into apps or
dashboards with a click of a
button and so when deepnote was founded
in 2019 there were a couple of questions
that were top of mind that we were
thinking a lot about and that we we
wanted to have answered and they were
how can we make data more accessible and
understandable how can we facilitate
conversations around data and
insights and how can we help data teams
collaborate
better um at the same time we were also
noticing some major Trends going on in
the data space um for example the
explosion of data
roles more remote first Workforce
and also the rise of the citizen data
scientist and for those of you who have
never heard that term we um think of
those people as business personas or
somebody who is not traditionally
trained in data science who still has to
interact with data and data science
principles in any way to be able to do
their everyday
jobs and at the center of all three of
those major movements that we going on
is data
democratization we saw data
democratization as the key um difference
between this state where data science um
where the data science process only
involves those who are considered pure
data
scientists um and this after state where
um where you are involving the people
who are outside of that um that
traditional data org and um this is
where the citizen data scientists come
in um the we needed to know where to
focus our efforts and put our heads down
to build something meaningful that could
tackle all three of these questions um
that we were thinking a lot about and
and we started to crack at those
questions by bringing in um the answer
of data science
notebooks and when you hear the phrase
data science notebooks apparently 80% of
data scientists think about and use
Jupiter notebooks
specifically however when the rest of
the World Hears the the term Jupiter
notebooks they usually think about a
very Niche tool that mostly serves
technical audiences
only oops and going back to these three
trends that we were observing at the
time we noticed that there was a gap in
tools that served the plenty of um
citizen data science roles that were
coming online that also happened to be
remote first
roles and that's where collaborative
data science notebooks come in our
prediction is that collaborative data
science notebooks uh is the answer to
unlocking not only true collaboration
within data science teams but also
between those regular and citizen data
science
teams in order to predict the future of
notebooks and specifically collaborative
notebooks um however we would need to go
back in time and understand its history
and then from there we will cover some
of the best practices that we recommend
for achieving that ideal future state
where there is fluidity between um those
regular data scientists and the citizen
data
scientists the very first notebook was
introduced in 1988 by Wolfram
Mathematica and it very much targeted a
technical crowd and because of that very
Niche nature of it it took a back seat
to
spreadsheets um spreadsheets started
with the introduction of vizzy C in
1979 uh followed by lotus 123 in
1983 um but as history would have it
both of those would be beat out by excel
in 1987 when it was introduced um which
of course that remains the market leader
in in
spreadsheets and with that spreadsheets
really became the preferred business
application and notebooks really faded
to the
background that is until Jupiter came
along with the release of IPython 0.12
in December of 2011 almost exactly 12
years ago to this
day and so that came along 20 years
after that first notebook was released
in 1988 by Wolfram Mathematica this new
browser-based interactive notebook uh
provided a cell-based execution workflow
um that was really meeting the market
demand at the time for a new way to
analyze large volumes of unstructured
data that a spreadsheet could not handle
due to the Infamous 1 million row limit
per sheet and but what happened between
2011 and now to make notebooks that
preferred format for data
scientists to understand the notebooks
of today however we have to dive into um
understanding the trade-off between
usability and power that all technical
tools
encounter historically spreadsheets have
sat closer to the usability end of this
spectrum because they're so easy to use
that Excel us users don't even realize
their writing software with it um
however they are hard to scale um
because of again that 1 million row
limit uh however notebooks and idees on
the other hand sit closer to the power
end of the spectrum because of the high
cealing of what you can do with code but
they also have a much higher barrier to
entry somewhere in the middle of this
spectrum is is a an Ideal tool with the
accessibility and simplicity of a
spreadsheet but also the scalability and
power of
code so we enter modern notebooks to
bridge that Gap with these following
critical elements to be able to serve
today's data science teams we have a
text component for you to add context um
to the analysis that you're conducting
we have SQL queries to be able to um
bring in the data that you're working
with you also have code to add the logic
around those queries a visualization
layer to present the code to your
business stakeholders and lastly a
commenting capability to allow for
feedback and iteration on those
presentations that you're
giving so you may think that data
scientists are the only ones who can
benefit from these modern um notebooks
and for all intents and purposes I've
been saying data scientists data
scientists data scientist throughout
this
presentation but in addition to um data
scientists being those first order users
who um are power users of notebooks
there are also mlops folks and data
Engineers who are included in that first
order even though they are doing things
that are completely different in the
data science
spectrum and additionally within each of
these different types of personas there
are also different proficiency levels
beginners are going to require a lot
more handholding when it comes to
building models and building reports
whereas the more advanced personas um
with them collaboration would shift more
towards the needs of reproducibility
versioning and so on some other skills
to call out that really distinguish
those beginners from Advanced users are
things like working with Git managing
clusters and writing quality python
code and so now that we have a better
understanding of the people who are
using notebooks let's take a look at how
they
collaborate historically data science
teams have been siloed off in a
centralized team with it an org to do
whatever it is that data science teams
do in what feels like a black box to
those Outsiders um independent of what
those Outsider teams are
doing collaboration for all intents and
purposes up to this point has meant the
collaboration that is happening within
members um sitting in those data science
teams but a more ideal level of
collaboration
is when data science teams are empowered
to really collaborate with those other
non-technical teams outside of the data
org to be able to enrich their findings
with domain knowledge make their
findings discoverable throughout the
organization and also bring in those
citizen data scientists into the their
workflows and all of those things are
really only possible when those
non-technical citizen data science teams
can also Al communicate back with the
data
scientists but in reality the ideal uh
state of that ideal state of
collaboration is held back by different
teams different work mediums for example
if an analyst wants to send their model
to an engineer for
implementation um but the engineer can't
figure out how to run it or they most
definitely cannot figure out how to
leave feedback on the model then that
ideal state of collaboration that I just
highlighted comes crashing
down and so what we need is a
fundamentally different medium from the
tools of the
past we really see notebooks as that
solution that can bring together Silo
tools and practitioners to be the center
of gravity for that Vision that I have
outlined so um now we're going to cover
best practices for working together in a
data team so that we can get to that
Vision um these are going to be
principles that you should follow no
matter the type of project that you're
working on um using
notebooks
okay one um there should be a place
where data scientists can just write
code when say an idea pops into their
head or they need to do some very quick
and dirty exploratory analysis plenty of
data scientists have Jupiter installed
on their own machine and they've figured
out the most efficient way um to run it
for their own personal workflows but
this is not a good practice um when the
company needs to scale and so when you
turn to cloud-based notebooks um that
those individual setups are prepared for
scalability and um some other examples
of some good
cloud-based notebook platforms are AWS
stagemaker and the Google AI
platform the second principle notebooks
should not uh only be readon um it
should those notebooks should serve as a
place where you can collaborate by
easily making big or small changes to
others codes uh others code without
having to go back and forth over email
or slack or some other medium separate
from from that coding medium um even
worse would be uh even worse than readon
notebooks would be um screenshots of
code in notebooks um and that is
probably even more
common my third tip for um my third best
practice for working with notebooks is
that there should be a robust way to do
Version Control and track changes
because with collaboration comes higher
chances of of accidents happening uh
between team members like possibly
deleting somebody else's code and that
may or may not have happened to a friend
of mine um and that friend had her butt
saved by Version Control
features fourth in order to make your
notebooks reproducible to hand off to
any collaborators you need to have
explicit documentation of the
requirements um some of those best
practices for this include never using
local files um and those Cloud
environments really force you to do that
also uh follow python the the python
best practice of listing your packages
used in a requirements text file no
matter the type of analysis you're
doing and Fifth and the most probably
the most U critical way to facilitate
collaboration is being able to leave
feedback for your collaborators so that
um you can iterate so that you can
create an iterative process
together and so given these another set
of best practices that I will be going
through um may not be as necessary uh to
follow if you're a data science uh
Persona that is mostly concerned with
exploratory programming however if you
are writing code that needs to end up in
production which a lot more data science
uh people these days are concerned with
then we have also some software
development best
practices first there is no way around
writing code and and tests um it's
absolutely a must but fortunately
notebooks make that easier by providing
that that text layer for you to write
that all
out second um log all your experiments
as you're doing them notebooks uh today
today like deepnote offer Integrations
with hosted experimentation tracking
tools like tensor board ml flow and
Great
Expectations third split your
development and production environments
um whenever possible and a lot more uh
data scientists these days are are
finding themselves needing to do that so
that they can um work with data and
sanitize it in a secure development
environment that is um in a separate
place within your
servers especially when you are
collaborating with others parameterizing
your notebooks is super important this
means putting all of your your um inputs
at the top of your notebook so that when
a collaborator comes in they know the
variables that they have to change
within the first few lines of code
rather than making them hunt for for
those requirements um hundreds of lines
down in your
notebook and lastly think about
continuous integration with each change
that you make to your code there should
be robust tests um to ensure that you
are not um that you are not breaking
anything down the line which could
impact all of your
collaborators and so with these coding
and notebook best practices in mind we
are confident that we'll get to that
Vision where data science is embedded
throughout organizations and the citizen
data scientist really becomes um just as
important in the data science process as
traditional data scientists
are and that is it um would love to open
the floor for some questions
now sure so why is it so difficult to um
integrate
G uh into G workflows and so what we
were finding here at deepnote is that um
those python files um when you upload
them to to get they are very static
pieces of document that yes they're
brought into those git workflows I me
that's supposed to facilitate um
collaboration but that collaboration is
done in a medium that is outside of
where that python um coding is happening
in those files and so you can still have
a lot of um
asynchronous um like you can still have
a lot of those those issues come into
play where um versioning is is happening
somewhere else and people are working
with not the latest python file and so
with the data science notebooks that
deep node is creating we're really
ensuring that um the the versioning and
the coding and the documentation steps
are all done in um one place rather than
having to to like upload it somewhere
else um that is another source of truth
that you have to deal
with okay um second question if we could
bring that one up from
Tony um yes so deepnote does help with
versioning of data I should probably
have um let me pull up a quick demo
and sign into
that um okay if I bring this to this
screen um if we can uh hold on let me
share oh okay um so the question is does
deepnote help with versioning of data
also the answer is yes and so um let me
share that on the screen so that this
question can can disappear here and I
can show you what it looks like in in
deep
note um
here you see here um my notebook uh with
its visualization blocks and um
exploratory data frame or data frame
exploratory features that are natively
built in um but also up top we have a
lot of the features that work outside of
just the the coding that's happening
within notebook and
here um we have the the versioning and
you see a very detailed log of
everything that I've done um if you have
multiple users working in the same
notebook you'll see them pop up uh here
as bubbles similar to Google Docs if
they are in here at the same time but
this versioning um will track everybody
else's ver uh changes as well and you
can always roll back to any of um those
those prior
versions okay
any other questions that we
have um okay
so I don't think that there are any more
questions but um I'm happy to hang
around for the last couple um to answer
anybody else's um that they might think
of last minute and um if oh okay here's
another
one what does um kernel configuration
look like for multilanguage notebooks um
so I probably can't speak to the the
super technical aspects of this but um
deepnote definitely does support
multiple languages within one notebook
um do I show it in
here okay maybe not let me show you guys
another example of a
different um notebook where we do have
like say SQL and python uh within the
same notebook so you'll notice here I'm
in my own personal workspace but I also
have access to a bunch of other
workspaces and workspaces are how um in
deepnote you organize all your team's
work um settings and permissions that
are set in in one workspace will persist
through all projects within um the same
workspace so that everybody um Can
collaborate on the same level and there
they are starting from the same Baseline
but let's say if I jump into this
example notebook of a turn prediction um
dashboard I
have I have multiple um notebooks
organized within my project and I can
jump to each of these but let's say in
my exploratory data analysis notebook
here um you can see I have SQL happening
here and um let's see where's my python
happening um some pretty basic python
that's happening here and jumping into
the actual machine learning step where
we're building a random Force classifier
this is where you'll see a lot of the um
this is this will be a strictly python
uh notebook but you'll also notice that
there are different types of blocks such
as these um input blocks where you can
adjust these inputs and the rest and
those changes will persist throughout
this notebook um and that makes it a
truly um interactive space for both the
the people who are those Technical
personas and any stakeholders who are
coming in here and want to play with the
models themselves so you can see all
this the python here and then in my
summary notebook um again you'll see a
mix of these input blocks SQL blocks um
and python blocks Al together and most
notably this um interactive no code
visualization block so I think this um
this summary notebook is really uh where
showcase uh all all of those different
types of blocks working
together um let's see another question
that we have is there a get repo
underneath deepnote so we do have an
integration um built out with uh with
GitHub so that you can push easily push
your deep note notebooks to to GitHub as
well um in terms of the specific repo
though I would have to dig that up um if
we have a deepnote app how can we share
a workspace with a non deepnote user is
there external link sharing yes so great
question if I could uh flash this back
up yes so you were um you're one step
ahead of me so these apps here are like
I said they can be built with a click of
a button off of any notebook that you
have and so with this notebook um the
summary notebook I've already created an
App here so um but if I hadn't created
this there should be a button to to like
create app up here and you can configure
exactly how you want that notebook to be
shown whether you want to have all your
code blocks and your output blocks shown
or you only want the output blocks shown
or if you want to configure it to be
like um like full SC like full wide
screen or if you wanted to like have all
your um your blocks centered in the
screen like this but that's all
configurable and then I would create app
and this is what the app would look like
where if I select this input here it
should um run the rest of those
notebooks given that um that input But
to answer your question about how we can
share um this with non deepnote users um
once that runs I'll I'll flash that back
up on the screen but um if I edit app
you'll see these are the configurations
that I can adjust and you can see
sharing um I can either make the app
have the same permissions as the
underlying notebook or I can make it
sharable to anyone with this link or
completely public and if you select
public this app goes up into what is
known as like your your deepnote public
profile and similar to things like
kaggle you would have a page that is out
there for the world to see um displaying
all of your public projects but if you
don't choose this public um project then
the most common type of sharing is
anyone with a link um so that you can
simply copy this link um to oh okay well
that's a bug but yeah so we copy this
link and send it to anybody and they can
see um they can see the whole um uh app
and the underlying uh notebook